[Musique]
salut à tous il ya quelques temps début
2019 un petit groupe de militants noirs
la ligue de défense noire africaine à
manifester à paris devant l'exposition
toutankhamon accusant celle-ci de
blanchir le pharaon et de falsifier
l'histoire égyptienne
cet événement anecdotique m'a rappelé
l'existence dans les années 2000 d'un
groupuscule suprémacistes noir la tribu
ka dirigé par kémi séba qui avait fait
parler de lui en organisant des chasses
aux juifs et qui lui aussi croyez que
les pharaons étaient noirs et au passage
adhérer à une sorte de religion raciale
issue de cette soi-disant egypte antique
le quai mutisme du coup cette croyance
en une égypte noir intrigué et je me
suis intéressé aux groupuscules et
théories qui véhiculait cette idée
aujourd'hui je vous propose donc de
découvrir le monde assez fantasque des
afro centriste est tout d'abord d'où
viennent ses idées elles remontent
toutes plus ou moins directement au
travail d'une personne
cheikh anta diop un intellectuel
sénégalais ayant fait ses études en
france à la fois en physique et en
sciences sociales
ces idées couvrant à la fois l'histoire
l'anthropologie et la linguistique
peuvent se résumer à trois points
d'abord l'egypte antique était noir
l'aîné bien venant de l'actuel soudan
aurait descendu le nil pour coloniser
l'egypte diop apporte ce qu'il estime
être des preuves
les égyptiens nommer leur pays qu
émettent ce qu'il traduit par pays des
noirs
deuxième point toutes les cultures
africaines découle de cette culture
égyptienne [ __ ] africaine pour
reprendre les termes dans ta job
cette culture se seraient diffusées dans
toute l'afrique après un exode massif de
la population égyptienne
suite à l'invasion perse qui a eu lieu
vers 520 avant jésus-christ à l'appui
diop tente de montrer les similitudes
entre toutes les langues africaines et
la langue de l'ancienne egypte et entre
les structures sociales africaines
actuelles et celles qui avaient cours
dans l'ancienne egypte et dernière thèse
et pas des moindres la civilisation
égyptienne un [ __ ] africaines seraient
antérieurs à toutes les autres
civilisations humaines à qui elle aurait
communiqué ces savoirs en particulier la
grèce antique qui en fait n'aurait rien
inventé ni approfondies ni la
philosophie n'est la médecine
les mathématiques ou l'architecturé est
en fait tu devrais tout à l'egypte
cette thèse sera publié en livre sous le
titre nations [ __ ] et culture et
donnera naissance à l'afro centrisme oif
rossant tricité courant qui postulent
l'importance vitale de l'afrique dans
l'émergence de la civilisation et dans
l'histoire humaine largement hors du
continent africain par exemple anta diop
estimait que bouddha avait des traits
africains et supposait il s'agissait en
fait d'un prêtre égyptien ayant fui le
pays après les invasions perse notant
aussi qu'est la même époque le
confucianisme et le zoroastrisme émergé
en extrême orient il laisse
sous-entendre que là aussi il pourrait
s'agir de création de prêtres égyptiens
en exil si ces idées peuvent paraître
étrange
d'autres à sa suite sont allées encore
beaucoup plus loin comme on le verra
alors qu'en penser dès le début les
théories de cheikh anta diop ont été
très contestées
ainsi il n'a pas pu passer sa thèse
initiale sur le sujet ces travaux sur
l'egypte [ __ ] africaines n'ont jamais
été publiés dans des revues à comité de
lecture et lui même a longtemps été
employée dans un laboratoire de physique
et mon histoire ou de sciences humaines
il faut dire que le président sénégalais
d'époque léopold sédar senghor se méfier
de ces théories
en clair son idée d'une égypte [ __ ]
africaine n'a jamais été validé par la
communauté scientifique
ces thèses ou fait polémique au point
que l'unesco a dû organiser une
conférence pour en débattre
mais elles n'ont jamais eu d'écho
favorable ensuite parmi les spécialistes
et ses hypothèses afrocentrique ont été
contredites par des études ultérieures
d'abord le terme kemet que diop traduit
par pays des noirs
les égyptologues le traduisent plutôt
par terre noire ou pays de la terre
noire en référence au sol fertilisé par
le limon des crues du nil
il serait d'ailleurs étonnant qu'un
peuple antique se nomme par la couleur
de sa peau
cette idée traduisant plutôt l'obsession
raciale de diop il utilise aussi des
exemples parmi les objets égyptiens en
sélectionnant quelques sources allant
dans son sens parmi des milliers
possible et les interprètes
systématiquement selon ses désirs
une statue au teint noir ou une peinture
noire traduit la négritude de la peau
égyptienne mais dans le même temps les
peintures montrant des personnages aux
peaux claires là par contre traduirait
une pratique ancienne d'éclaircissement
de la peau les tests adn sont venus
régler cette question et montre que les
égyptiens n'étaient absolument pas noir
pour la plupart on sait juste qu'il y a
eu une dynastie de pharaon noir la 25e
ch'ti et c'est tout quant à l'idée que
l'égyptien serait la langue mère de
toutes les langues d'afrique noire
partie importante de l'oeuvre de diop
des linguistes rejette cette idée en
bloc et inclut les gypsies anciens dans
la famille des langues afro asiatique et
non des langues d'afrique noire on peut
aussi reprocher à ces thèses de tout
voir à travers le prisme raciale noir
blanc et ainsi de jeter à la poubelle
toute une histoire qui n'est ni blanche
ni noire mais constitué de peuples
aujourd'hui disparue et qui pourtant ont
été fondamentaux dans l'histoire de
l'humanité comme les mésopotamiens par
exemple
à cela ajoutons que la vision du
obtiennent de l'histoire est très 19e
siècle et prix scientifique
ainsi dans son monde en noir et blanc il
voyait les asiatiques comme des hybrides
des deux autres races en résumé cheikh
anta diop a produit un travail
extrêmement biaisé intellectuellement ou
tout systématiquement interprété via son
obsession raciale son travail n'est pas
réellement scientifique car il s'agit
avant tout d'une démarche politique
diop était panafricaniste vous voulez
une afrique unie dans un état fédéral
et comme par hasard ces thèses en
égyptologie vont dans le sens de ses
idées politiques
alors bien sûr pour comprendre pourquoi
ce travail était aussi biaisés
intellectuellement il faut resituer
cheikh anta diop dans son contexte à
savoir les années 50 à 70
l'époque est à la décolonisation et au
racisme est sympa on voit encore
l'afrique comme un continent peuplé de
gentils sauvage un brin bébêtes est pas
bien méchant mais qui n'ont aucune
histoire et n'ont rien apporté à
l'humanité
si ce n'est une force de travail un
volontaire via l' esclavage et la
colonisation
il veut redonner de la fierté aux noirs
et prend donc le contre-pied de cette
vision négative
quitte à aller dans l'extrême inverse
créant de fait le mythe d'une race noire
supérieur créatrice de la civilisation
une sorte de mythe à rien ou atlante
made in africa c'est une histoire fausse
mais aussi complotistes si l'on doit
tout à la culture égyptienne un [ __ ]
africaine alors pourquoi ne nous la
prendrons pas l'école est bien pensé et
hop c'est parce que l'occident falsifie
l'histoire et cache la vérité par tous
les moyens depuis deux siècles
ils accusent par exemple les
égyptologues d'avoir irradié la momie de
ramsès 2 pour la blanchir
alors aujourd'hui que reste-t-il des
idées dans ta gueule dans la recherche
historique occidental absolument rien
par contre
a essaimé dans des milieux moins
conventionnelle est beaucoup moins
regardants sur la rigueur scientifique
d'abord en afrique et surtout au sénégal
où il est un héros national
l'université de dakar porte son nom et
son bras droit théophile obenga qui
continue son oeuvre
ces théories ont aussi pris racine dans
certains labos américain de black ou
american studies labo créés à partir des
années 70 après la vague des droits
civiques
ces labos ont permis d'entrer dans la
recherche universitaire de militants
noirs qui ont apporté leur matériel
militant dont diop
souvent ces chercheurs se sont contentés
d'approfondir la pseudo histoire de
l'egypte négro-africaine de broder des
philosophies dessus tel molefi à santé à
l'université de temple maulana karanga à
l'université de long beach
inventeur d'ailleurs de la fête
afro-américaine de kwanza mais d'autres
ont été plus imaginatifs
ainsi il va en vendre certina de
l'université de cornell affirme que les
indiens d'amérique ont été signalisés
par des explorateurs africains qui
auraient ainsi découvert l'amérique
largement avant les européens vers 700
avant jésus-christ une expédition
composée d'égyptiens noir et de
phéniciens ayant pour but d'aller
chercher des métaux en angleterre aurait
dérivé et se serait retrouvé en amérique
centrale où elle aurait été accueilli
par les olmèques les égyptiens auraient
alors communiquer leur savoir aux mecs
et les aurait dirigé leur communiquant
leurs connaissances religieuses médical
architectural d'où les pyramides
américaine et la momification
l'argument principal de ventes certes
ima et la forme négroïde est et est
sculpté olmèques qui représenteraient
les explorateurs involontaire il affirme
aussi qu'une autre expédition aurait eu
lieu vers 1300 après jésus-christ et
serait le fait de membres de l' empire
malien qui aurait accosté en amérique
centrale
transmettant là encore leur savoir
rachidi lui avance que l'asie a était
civilisé par les africains et que le
premier show good du japon était noir
martin bernal lui affirme que les grecs
auraient tout volé aux égyptiens noir
alors jusqu'à affirmer catena était la
copie d'une déesse égyptienne la
civilisation grecque représentant
symboliquement le début de la culture
occidentale la dévalorisation de celle
ci est d'ailleurs une marotte
afrocentriste bref diop à lui de
multiples continuateurs tout ce que je
vous ai cités sont liés de près ou de
loin à la recherche universitaire et
leurs thèses soit enseignée dans
certains cursus mais d'autres beaucoup
plus fantasques hors des cercles
académiques ou pousser l'imagination
beaucoup plus loin
ainsi il y en a eu pour prétendre que la
civilisation égyptienne maîtriser la
télépathie ou l'aéronautique
aussi grotesque que cela puisse paraître
cette idée s'est retrouvé dans du
matériel pédagogique aux usa au nom du
multiculturalisme c'est aussi sur cette
pseudo histoire que se base le quai
mutisme religion newedge censé
reconstituer celle de l'égypte [ __ ]
africaines dont se réclamait kemi seba
et dont se réclament aussi certains
autres panafricaniste les tests diop
yens trouve naturellement un large écho
dans cette sphère panafricaniste pour ce
que j'ai pu voir
l'adhésion à cette thèse et est totale
par exemple en france on a la ligue de
défense noire africaine dont la
mobilisation contre l'exposition
toutankhamon a pour base les théories
diop yens mais on a aussi le collectif
afro féministe moisi qui a défrayé la
chronique en organisant un festival en
partie interdit aux blancs qui fait la
promotion d'un livre d'histoire
alternatif pour les enfants dont
l'auteur avoue qu'elle est inspirée par
diop et ses continuateurs et puis ces
théories pseudo historique sont aussi
une porte d'entrée pour des délires
racialiste puisqu'ils sont issus d'une
civilisation supérieure qu'on a spolié
de son histoire
pourquoi les noirs ne serait-il pas
aussi une race génétiquement supérieur
certains dans les milieux panafricain
propage la théorie de la mélanine créé
par française cresswell singh étant
donné que la majeure partie de la
population mondiale ait foncé de powell
singh voit la blancheur comme une
anomalie et surtout comme une maladie
elle estime que les blancs sont des
descendants d'africains albinos qui ont
dû fuir l'afrique à cause de cette
maladie
elle explique que cette blancheur
minoritaires crée une insécurité chez
les blancs qui ont donc essayé de
dominer les noirs via l' esclavage et s
est encore via les drogues ou la
promotion de l'homosexualité dans la
communauté noire
d'autres à sa suite ont imaginé que la
mélanine donne des super pouvoirs comme
une plus grande empathie ou bien une
plus grande proximité avec dieu en
france en 2010 est elle lieu une
conférence de l'association
panafricaniste afro centre et cité
internationale ou la dirigeante ama
mazama a promu cette théorie expliquant
donc que les blancs sont des albinos des
êtres anormaux et cetera le tout devant
un public conquis
ama mazama est aussi le bras droit de
mme hall efficacité à l'université de
tempel avec qui elle a fondé cette
association
également on peut aussi trouver des
traces des théories afrocentrique dans
des publications de la brigade anti
négrophobie ou dans celle du cran qui
fait carrément la promotion du français
chrys racing en fait l'oeuvre de diop et
de ses continuateurs fourni ce que
j'appellerais
des références de basse intensité à
savoir qu'individuellement ce ne sont
pas des références absolues comme marx
pour les communistes par exemple mais
ensemble ils forment une trame globale
un imaginaire raciale diffus qui fournit
une justification intellectuelle au
militantisme
voilà donc d'où viennent et jusqu où
s'étendent les théories afrocentriste et
panafricanistes si cette vidéo vous a
intéressé n'hésitez pas à la partager
moi je vous donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine émission d'ici là je vous dis
portez vous bien et à la prochaine
[Musique]